my favorite part of being a youtuber is
the comment section if the interactions
that I get with my audience I mean the
fact that I can make something upload it
and then instantly have a direct
conversation with my audience is just
the best
sometimes it's wonderful constructive
criticism saying ooh I like this maybe
you can do this better next time and
that's the best con comment sometimes
it's just people saying I really like
this sometimes sometimes they're not so
nice and you get really abusive comments
but sometimes just sometimes you get
gloriously weird comments and I just so
happen to keep the collection of
screenshots of my favorite weird
comments on my phone so that's what this
video is going to be about now I'm not
going to include user names because I
don't make a martyr out of anybody but
these are all 100% real unedited
comments that I've received over the
past two years or so be honest where did
you hide the poem you being so posh &
proper probably masturbated to Victorian
or Elizabethan porn law apart from the
finesse Q is blowing and the endemic spy
rings Cambridge is academically far
superior than Oxford hi Simon
are you autistic can you do a video
about how to overcome the challenge of
autism I would be really grateful this
is a two-parter
[ __ ] your life and then on the next
video in the playlist cue light part 2
your voice is smooth as [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
my ovaries are exploding this one starts
out like a tongue twister learning
physics so you can teach physics to
future physics students you will
eventually teach physics to other
younger physics students in ordained to
sustain this huge intellectual
masturbation Ponzi scheme scam I'm sure
you'll get a big fat government check
for your lifetime achievements - you
[ __ ] worthless wanker surprisingly
for a British you look very good I think
this one might have actually been a
response to that previous one um though
he still is handsome I think he was much
more as an undergrad at that time he had
a nicer cleaner haircut his lips with
dinner and his face was more round
cheeks thinner also now he has one eyes
slightly bigger than the other what
language is he speaking possibly my
favorite of all
I'm on my first week in the life vlog
title nonsense each shot of us just
following you around would have taken at
least 15 to 30 minutes to set up each
this was filmed over several days
it also doesn't sound like a typical day
for any PhD student in stem
shame on you Exeter go spend your
students money on proper adverts are not
this Sai option it Simon I see that you
use pen for note is there a reason for
that
find a man that looks at you the way
Simon looks at r2d2 if I want to run
errands of music or in a bakery having
my subject as physics your PhD paper
will never be bigger than your half
prince for effect I have shown that the
damn
we found it funny so this one was in
response to somebody said are you gay
and I replied are you serious and then
they replied with just out of the blue
yes and yes being from Europe I would
hope you are uncut and you act gay so
I'm just putting two and two together
there is a 1/4 chance you'll cut one in
four that you're uncut and a one in four
that you have a vag and finally a one in
four have no sex organs I know it's kind
of personal though it's just human
nature so no need to get all bent over
it humans are too prudish if you ask me
everyone generally has a dick or vag so
why not put it out there I say love as
for being gay if you are I would love to
take you out when I'm in Europe for a
few months this coming year I resist
that kind of offer you have [ __ ] tips
you're a socialist are you into stuff
that doesn't work with your coat print
is it hard or something do you get
confused confused emoji female symbol
hello years do you have to study sorry
for panicking my stupid girl better
discover something crazy or you will end
up becoming another high school science
teacher with a third queue you are so
successful is he a relative you know the
Smithsonian Institute has been hauled
into court for destroying for the last
hundred years giant skeletons of human
beings these skeletons
2:246 feet high they over North America
this totally throws hit his 70,000 year
whole evolution thing out of the window
the most interesting YouTube video I
have seen since gangbang style your
social skills are dogs a special
appearance from Twitter hey Simon quick
tip do put some effort on your hairstyle
Ryan I swear to God if this is because
of you he's probably a [ __ ] on the
side with a mouth like that mate I don't
think I'll be as good as you what
happened to you you were mega cute in
your old videos now you're all masculine
and boring I remember this one polish if
you changed a lot you looked like either
a football player with really large
shoulders or a person with a really
small head and average-sized head maybe
it is the camera but it sure doesn't
seem like it the Horace Simon's videos i
watch the moral conscience car in the
face love you though well I guess you
don't have enough work if you have time
to do these videos you look like a broad
in Japan if he never went to Japan I
don't say this often but douche 5 SEC's
in and that's the word that came to mind
Simon Clarke more like same old fart
ha let me guess you don't have a
girlfriend and thought you could find
one this way without the help of tinder
or bar visits virgin plants people brag
about their PhDs and I'm just sitting
here masturbating to the non-virtuous
business where is the uninstall button
for YouTube why is this in my
recommended I hate all English rich
people quite fine with me then you can
buy a PhD on the street so sorry you can
buy a food on the street for about 1000
bucks and not waste seven years of your
young life where's your dealer I want to
talk to him and then penultimately to
conversations next to each other in my
feed so this was I woke up one day and I
just saw these two things how old are
you since he complains about not having
much pubic hair
I would guess around 15 and I agree you
look a lot like Sophia man especially
when you wear tight t-shirt
showing your nipples you also have
similar speaking styles and of course
you're both intelligent and sing choral
music I don't notice the parallels are a
tribute a parody or coincidental but I
like it and when someone replying to
that I heard that men wearing bras and
bloomers that their thesis defense was
an Oxford tradition
perhaps Thailand was honouring that
tradition do know where to start with
that lot and finally another special
edition from Twitter which is what
prompted me to make this video give us
possibly my favorite tweet I've ever
received
hey I'm really drunk at a drag show and
I just wanted to tell you how much you
inspire me I'm crying a lot see you
that's positive Angela that made my day
if you are watching this and you are
yourself eg but I would love to see your
version of this video or if you just
like to comment with your weirdest
comment you've ever received
it's a strange life picking youtuber
this is one of the perks apologies for
being absent by the way from YouTube for
a little while as I post it on my
community tab because I now have one of
those because be cheap next up I was a
vaction for about three weeks because
one I was at YouTube Nextup and two I
was quite poorly I actually had a wisdom
tooth come through that got badly
infected so I was out of action for over
a week with that so I'm sort of rushing
to catch up with you too but never fear
this is now out tomorrow I'm going to be
releasing the next of crash-course
cryosphere
which as I said a bit of a gap for
because life just got in the way for Tom
and I was looking very busy as well as
that there is a whole week long vlog
about YouTube Nextup which is going to
be coming out this week
very shortly there's also going to be a
full length episode about my last week
of term which happened a couple of weeks
ago at like 30 40 minute vlog rather
than splitting it up and on top of that
there's also a book video coming soon
it's not the book club because then I
still got to finish brief history of
time but I'm gonna be talking about some
of the books behind me actually I've
been reading recently so lots of
exciting stuff coming soon on the
channel I'm really excited to put into
actions and the stuff I learned that
next up so I'm not least in the next up
vlog so I hope you enjoyed this video do
give it a like if you did enjoy it if
you are a youtuber watching this do
comment down there with the strangers
comment that you've ever received and if
you're new on this channel
hello there's a button over here and a
video that's recommended for you that
you can click if you want to subscribe
I'll see you around thanks for watching